huh I'm okay thank you sure no no no
it's a geyser sure no guys Sean's are
great now see I am afraid ultimately I
don't wait to hold your baby Shawn
Mendes is at BuzzFeed today and he's
here to let all his twitter followers
make his decisions for him why are we
talking about it let's just start the
video let's do this hey whatever I was
going good nice to meet you Sean yeah
thanks for being here yeah let's get
down to it you just got off a tour even
traveling all around performing for
millions millions of people I thought
since you're here you could have all
your fans decide what you do with
BuzzFeed Gary yeah I know it's kind of
the treasure man that's how they're
gonna take carrier and make me do this
weirdest possible thing probably yeah so
your most popular song stitches it's
about kissing and stitches I thought
we'd have you sent a tweet app asking
your fans should I do a video where I
kiss a bunch of people or watch a video
where people actually get stitches okay
how's your day been
finally wait 10 minutes no random I hung
out with Larry King earlier so well
we're excited yeah I'm sure oh yeah
who's better-looking who's
better-looking um you know Larry had
this beautiful hairstyle happening so
I'm sorry he wins but you know introduce
yourself times people ask him if it's
okay to give a little kiss you know you
can do I kiss you on the forehead thank
you yes of course thank you
there's okay to kiss you on the forehead
just one quick kiss on the forehead
thank you I promise you this is just as
weird for me as it is for you yeah would
you like to kiss on the forehead one
that kiss you yeah thank you
ma'am can I please kissed you on the
forehead this week also oh this is an
awesome fact I'm extremely allergic to
dogs it's about a story is spontaneous
and I don't know so we'll see yeah I
also like how you grabbed everyone's
head so physically they are gonna taste
oh wow that's nice we're gonna go to
another room we're gonna sit on actually
you don't wash my my face cuz I'm the
dog oh the dog yeah I say like this
people aren't that dirty you guys need
to dog a dog yeah cuz you're allergic
your lips are really itching a little
itchy I'm sorry about that you're
Canadian
you probably know a lot about Canada hmm
so I like I imagine you were very
confident or not yeah I'm gonna have
your Twitter fans decide which way I'm
going to challenge you on your Canadian
knowledge so you can either label a
Canadian map you can try to identify a
fact that's not true
about Canada or you can try to spot a
Canadian in a lineup of people all right
okay we got away five minutes now and
then we're gonna see how Canadian you
really aren't how can even do you think
you are not that well like very Canadian
yeah we're not a Canadian scholar No
so your first fact is you can actually
call the Canadian government at 1-800 Oh
Canada right there is a small fishing
village in Newfoundland named dildo your
third fact is a 2013 poll found that 27
percent of Canadian participants believe
that hipsters should be forced to pay a
special tax for being annoying how does
anybody know these honestly like if
there was a place in the world that
there would be a town named dildo it
would be in Newfoundland but also like
that's a very Canadian thing to do is
Ford f-100 Oh Canada so hold up the one
you think is fake
I hope hipsters don't get offended by me
by saying that I think this is fake you
think okay and it is fake yeah okay
there's true
it's hipsters is fake it's actually an
American poll found that we believe
there should be it oh thank god it's an
American thing yeah but you still got it
wrong okay so we're gonna move on to the
next poll we have a little bit of time
are you hungry at all yeah if you're
hungry would you want to go maybe go get
some fast food okay so we're about to go
we're gonna send out a tweet you're
going to decide whether or not you're
going to sing your order whether or not
you order 20 things or if you're gonna
pay for a normal order in pennies boom
there it is yeah I'm sorry keep in my
nose but there's I'm well I understand
it alright don't put this all on me I'll
take some of the blame but the end of
the day you kissed the dog sing your
order I knew it I mean you're a singer
that's what they want okay
there's hamburgers cheeseburgers don't
get the chili on it it's too much
hi can I please get a hamburger with
chili on top and maybe some cheese fries
with that yeah that would be all thank
you
decided to get
chili said not to get the chili thank
you so much thank you I was way too much
chili on this show and said I didn't
want it
oh no the chili ruins it
what's next oh you're gonna go sing you
a baby okay
what's clutch did I sing do it baby
how about twinkle twinkle little star
link'll do you know rockabyebaby said
okay
the itsy-bitsy spider do you know that
one yeah that's good solid right great
you sent out the poll so we'll find out
what we seem to the baby it's the cutest
little baby I'm long as you're gonna
sing me because I don't want the baby to
judge me
you want me to sing to you or with with
the baby with not with Nicky baby with
me dancing with you to the baby well
this is Shawn Mendes nice to meet you
Ben we're gonna lots about you I'm a
very big fan to sit down here so this
shirt only wants milk ready okay twinkle
twinkle little star how I wonder what
you are up above the sky so bright like
a diamond in the sky twinkle twinkle
little star how I wonder what you are
I didn't realize there was a Canadian
version in American I didn't think that
I don't think there is I think I got the
lyrics wrong I think this was wrong but
anyways thank you for being such a good
baby since she cute yeah I think if I
was a baby and this was happening me I'd
be screaming Sheldon hot milk chug chug
chug chug I think you should no no no
it's a it's a show no guys showings are
great now see I am afraid all to be show
I don't need to hold your baby payment
right over don't even we look like we
look like an adorable couple
he didn't babysit when I'm like the ones
here don't
I know you want to give her a kiss on
the forehead sure you can
Thank You Shawn I hate to break it to
you but this video has to end soon but
is it yeah it does you have to leave you
have to go on into bigger and better
things Shawn I do so I thought we'd let
your Twitter followers decide how this
video ends and I thought maybe either we
could have an all-out breakup scene
we could have a passionate long hug
goodbye
yeah or we could do a where are they now
sequence five-minute Bowl we're going to
find out how this video ends and then
we're just gonna cut to right cut to the
ending they choose I'm gonna be a good
dad yeah that really came out of nowhere
that so you always get to clap well it's
just how we sync the camera Shawn it's
not supposed to be get it you work here
you always get to do the class oh my god
yeah other people like that I thought
today has just been wrong it's been
wrong I invite you over to my company to
make a video for your fans oh I didn't
want kiss people on the forehead II know
I do you want to make it more about
kissing you should I not on the forehead
I don't know I'm it has motion I would I
was upset in the cloud just dumped
should maybe I just don't know
[Music]
[Music]
you
come on Shawn let's get out of here
why Shawn Mendes will never forget you